at the end of the main video i mentioned  the title of baronet  and since i've gotten some questions  about it let me explain  in order of precedence baronets are  below barons  but above most knights but a baronet is  not a noble rank at all  they are not peers of great britain they  are commoners just like knights  unlike knights however their titles are  hereditary  the title was created in 1611 by king  james the first  to raise funds for his military james  offered the title  to land-owning gentlemen whose annual  income was at least one thousand pounds  a year  to receive the title these gentlemen had  to pay the crown 1095 pounds which at  the time  was enough to maintain 30 soldiers for  three years